[Music]
josh is with us
josh is in san antonio hi josh how are
you
i'm doing well dave how are you doing
today better than i deserve what's up
so i'm a realtor with the crisis of
conscience uh realtor
i also teach financial peace i'm
currently teaching my third class
and the thing i've come across
especially in these crazy times is
what do you do when you got these people
that the lender's like oh you got to go
get a credit card oh you got to go do
this debt
i've told people look there's other ways
to do this
and i've lost business you know and
that's fine god's taking care of my
family but
how do you approach this as a real
estate guy you've been this forever
you know doing both sides you know
you're talking about the
go get a credit card to build your
credit thing is that what you're talking
about
yes sir okay then what you have to have
is
you need to find how much volume do you
do how many houses a year do you sell
uh i do about about two million a year
um
it's long story how my my stuff floats
my family is
we've been debt-free for a while so
we're not having to go out and get every
single deal and just do whatever i try
to do mine
as biblically as possible which is kind
of hard to do sometimes
for sure sure well i and i think that
you know what we had to do uh in the
instance uh
20 plus years ago 25
years ago with churchill mortgage was
mike hardwick and i had to sit down and
say listen if i'm going to send folks to
churchill mortgage
uh and tell people that i never say
anything more than a 15-year fixed rate
where the payment is more than a fourth
of your take-home pay
and you need to be prepared to do manual
underwriting because
a lot of the people that do what i teach
are not going to have a credit score
and so you can't tell people to go get a
credit card when i just when the lead i
sent you just went through financial
peace university and i told them cut up
their credit cards
so we can't be it's inconsistent and
people get pissed off when you're
inconsistent because it feels like a
lack of integrity
um and so these are the discussions mike
and i had 25 years ago
and we've had him a few times since then
over the years as he's grown
and he you know he buys another comp
another mortgage company another city
and he has to teach them
you know the our way of looking at
things because if i send leads over
there they get mad
you know yeah and you got the same thing
it's not just a crisis of confidence
it's it's a
conscience but it's a they're they're
looking at us like we
like we lied or something you know and
so um
uh you know what i would tell you to do
is begin to develop just on a local
level
a relationship with a mortgage uh broker
a mortgage company that
um or maybe just an underwriter at one
of the companies or or
a uh you know a loan originator that's
just got you know they they get it
they you know they go through financial
peace university maybe you pay for it or
whatever
uh and and so that you can get aligned
on
when i send a customer over there i you
know i
i don't want to hear that you told him
to go get a credit card
right or i can't send you that business
yeah you know and so um
you know because i can't it's
inconsistent and and it
you know it's um it it you know
standard operating procedure in the
mortgage business won't work for me
and it won't work for you josh now
you're not saying i have trouble telling
them to get a mortgage because
you know that we all while we believe
the best thing is the 100
down plan we calm down a little bit and
allow a 15 year
in our guidelines knowing that with the
idea though that they're going to get it
paid off soon right
correct yeah yeah so that's not your
that's not your crisis
you know and i've actually had to walk
away from this i think the past two
years i've probably walked away from
about a million and a half in volume
just because
it wasn't going to be a good fit and i
didn't want to be the realtor to look
back on going
it's your fault i did this deal i don't
care about that you know it's better
though
yeah i mean you just have to somehow you
have to position yourself in the
customer's mind
that you're coaching them not just
selling them a house
correct okay and i think man and when
when you got a customer that's crazy and
they won't allow that
then they're not a customer exactly let
them go
let them go and then just leave with
your heart man you know just leave with
your heart
lead with the coaching lead with the
guidance and i think that will honestly
eventually earn you
more volume because i love
my real estate agent who's part of our
program
and as a guy who teaches it he's always
holding me accountable hey anthony
did you check your budget is that less
than 25
you know and i love that because i know
his heart is in the right place
uh so i would just say just leave with
your heart lead with the guidance lead
with the coaching
and i believe eventually it will bring
you more guidance
down the road not guidance but more
volume yeah i mean god's gonna bless the
intent of your heart here that's what it
amounts to so i think the thing you
want to be careful of and in my seat i
have to be careful of it as well
is to be persuasive and winsome
not legalistic yes be persuasive on the
principles and say
this is why yeah you know listen man
you're acting like you're gonna like you
you're gonna get alone here
you're not gonna be able to breathe and
i'm worried about you yeah
you know i think it's going to leave you
a bad place and i think you got a little
bit of house fever i think you need to
go
take a cold shower we need to rethink
you know if i was your
older brother if i was your dad you know
i would tell you
son don't do this and so i'm going to do
that because i care about you
and um and if you want if you're
hell-bent on driving your car off the
cliff you're going to do it by yourself
because i'm not going to participate in
that
dave if it what you just said is 10
times better than a
regular guy who's trying to get his
three percent oh yeah do whatever you
want to do let me just get the money
yeah you know
that well but not you know when
somebody's got house fever
yeah and they're hell-bent on doing
something stupid but and getting a loan
that's
55 of their take-home pay which they can
get approved for
on an adjustable rate mortgage that's
going to
ding them in a year and a half right
because it starts in the hole on the
index and they're going to come out
they're going to come out at 55 they're
going to be looking at 63 percent the
next year
and you know they're just hell-bent on
self-destruction because they got the
fever and they need that jacuzzi with a
skylight
and you can't stop stupid when it's on
when it's on a you know train
track heading down the heading off the
cliff and so
you know all you can do is get out of
the way and just you know wave the cape
and go olay
you know and just good luck with this
you know because i've tried to stop
stupid at my own friends you have to yes
yes
and they look at you with one eye yeah
you know and the other eye is looking
off somewhere else
it's weird yeah it's like they're
possessed and then when they do the
stupid
and they realize it's stupid they didn't
want to come back and apologize for the
stupidity i'm like no don't apologize
now
yeah you didn't hurt me nope
it was you i was trying to save you yeah
i'm not stupid not
as much as i used to be right
this is the ramsay show